ladies and gentlemen thanks so much for
joining us tonight my name is dawn
Lassiter and I've written about a dozen
true crime books and this is number 12
perfect justice and it's going to be my
pleasure tonight to tell you a little
bit about why we wrote that book and
about this gentleman seated here named
judge donald a mccarton McCartin is
probably one of the most interesting
sometimes controversial sometimes
humorous sometimes cantankerous judged
ever sit in Orange County he SAT he
presided over trials for 15 years from
what nineteen seventy eight to nineteen
ninety three when he retired and lives
now in Bass Lake California judge
mccarton tried about 300 murder trials
during his tenure in Orange County he
sent nine men to death row one of them's
name is Rodney Alcala some of you may
recall reading about Rodney because he's
been in the news lately and will be in
the news a lot more in the near future
we hope back in nineteen seventy nine a
little girl named Robin Sam so 12 years
old disappeared from Huntington Beach
Rodney Alcala was caught and tried for
murdering Robin Sam so in nineteen
eighty four years later the California
Supreme Court under Rose bird and some
of you may recall that name we booted
her out because we didn't like her very
much Rose bird overturned the trial and
sent out calla back to Orange County for
a second trial and that's when judged on
mccarton presided over a trial of Rodney
James alcala once again alcala was
convicted the jury came in with a guilty
verdict and Don mccarton sentenced him
to death row alcala sat in San Quentin's
death row for 23 years until a year ago
in june when the Ninth Circuit Court of
Appeals said
Don mccarton made judicial errors and
they reversed not only the death penalty
but the guilt verdict as well now Rodney
is back in Orange County sitting in your
jail at your taxpayers expense waiting
for yet a third trial when when this was
overturned in June last year I read the
headlines in the paper that day and I
was pretty disgusted and I waiting for
the phone to ring yeah and it rang with
about half an hour and judged on
mccarton said hey you're still writing
books nexted yeah I am is that lets do
one on this alcala case and tell my side
of the story so I agreed immediately and
that was on another project at the time
but finally earlier this year I went up
to sit with the judge in his place and
bass lake and we talked about the alcala
case yeah when I found out that judge
had sentence nine men to death row I
thought well that's got to be part of
the book as well so in this book perfect
justice you're going to read about
Rodney Alcala Robin samso and you're
also going to read about the other eight
men who were convicted by and sentenced
to death row by Judge mccarton among
them was Randy Steven craft Randy Kraft
was probably the most one of the most
prolific serial killers in US history
here in Orange County he was convicted
of killing 16 men it was guessed that he
probably killed over 60 homosexual
murders and Rodney or that is a craft
face mccarton and you taxpayers paid 10
million dollars over 12 months to
convict craft one of the other killers
that McCartin tried was a man named
James Gregory Marlow and 1986 Marlow and
his girlfriend Cynthia Lynn Kaufman
captured a young girl named lynel murray
and the prime cleaners in huntington
beach and and they took her to the
Huntington and which has since been
destroyed and they molested her horribly
and strangled her and left her there
dead they also killed another couple
people and they are both on death row as
well that was my first book I had met
Don mccarton when an roul was here in
town sitting in a chemical in his
courtroom when he was trying a man named
David Arnold brown some of you may
recall that name a brown put his little
13 year old daughter cinnamon real cute
little girl up to killing Browns current
wife cinnamon stepmother and with with
the excuse that well if you kill her
you'll just serve a few years in juvie a
bit high killer i'll have to go to jail
forever or death penalty and but he was
caught and judge judge tried him and he
didn't get death penalty though he got
life without parole but an rule was here
and SAT through that whole trial and
wrote a book called if you really love
me and rules book about judge McCartin
craft by the way was chronicled in this
book angel of darkness by a very
prominent true crime writer named Dennis
mcdougal so you folks if you hadn't
heard him a carton before must have
heard about him you readers at least of
true crime read about him in these two
books and also in my first book which is
called property the Folsom wolf that's
about Marlo and Kaufman who killed lynel
murray there was also a movie made of
the David David arnel Brown case a movie
for television and so this guy has been
pretty well chronicled in books and
movies what my first exposure to him was
when I came when I read in The Times one
day as reading when the craft trial was
going on and i read that this guy made
some decisions and i said well that's my
kind of judge that's the guys no
nonsense he's not a lying all the
baloney to take place that takes place
in most trials and I was so impressed I
decided I'd written any true crime at
that point but I drove over to Orange
County when in his courtroom and SAT
there and watched him for a while and I
said I like this guy and furthermore I
was really attracted to the idea that he
was humorous he didn't he takes trials
very seriously and he administers
justice I think as good as any judge
ever did but he also finds the use of
humor in his courtroom usually it's
it's directed himself or at other
lawyers for example i remember i think
i'm not sure which case it was maybe the
brown case in which he was doing jury
selection process and he turned to the
jurors said now in any of you lawyers
and he know any lawyers or did you ever
consider going to law school before you
regained your sanity and went into an
honest profession and that's what are
you going to sleep on me oh I know I
know I'm not as interesting as you are
believe me it was some sometimes he's
humor got him a little hot water every
once in a while he'd say things in the
courtroom that people took offense to
and sometimes he was accused of racial
slurs and other times he was accused of
not being entirely fair but I dispute
that he was as fair as any judge I've
ever seen when he retired in 1993 they
had a roast for him in which a reporter
from The Times this is not I mean from
the register got up and did a David
Letterman thing and cited the top ten
humorous things he's ever said regarding
alcala he faced alcohol and said you're
the most guilty man has ever come
through my courtroom and another another
guy was in there and the judge loaned
him a coat and tie his own personal coat
and tie because the guy was so sloppy
and then the judge told him no no matter
what I give you you still don't look
good he looked like a hobo yeah so I
thought this was AI thought this was
pretty great and so I I wrote my first
book with him in there and now when he
called me in June last year I said okay
it's it's time to do another one and I
really enjoyed going up and spending the
time up of bass lake with him to to get
his personal history and so I have
almost about a quarter of the book is
judgment cartons personal history in his
words his memoirs and for example I was
enjoy the part where he's in the US Navy
and his immediate superior to whom he
reported directly was Senator McCain's
father Admiral
later Admiral Jack McCain and I was also
interested in all the famous
personalities celebrities he ran across
he met John Wayne let me tell you just a
very brief little thing this is these
are all in the book he said when I was a
lawyer when I first opened my law
practice and Costa Mesa me and my
partner used to go downstairs to this
Orange Julius placed have an orange
julius almost every day next door was
Martin real estate company he said a
snotty-nosed little kid kept coming over
and just bugging us to death I didn't
like him very much but he did pretty
well his name was Steve Martin another
incident I thought was pretty
interesting he said that when I was that
when I was a lawyer we used to hire this
little private firm Farrell and Miller
or something to serve our papers they
were a little partnership you know and
they wanted businesses to serve papers
and he said later the ferrule didn't
like that very much he was an ex-marine
and he said he quit that and he went
into show business ain't Mike Farrell of
mash Fame now what's interesting about
this ironically if you remember earlier
this year there was a man who was
convicted of murder out in riverside
county and he was a kevin cooper and he
was scheduled to die earlier this year
and it was Mike Farrell whoo-hoo the
anti-death penalty coalition who got the
whole thing postponed by the Ninth
Circuit Court of Appeals we talk a lot
in the book about the Ninth Circuit
Court of Appeals were not real happy
with them in many cases and the judge
will have more to say to you about that
a little bit and he ran across a number
of personalities he told me about one
time when he moved to Costa Mesa to a
house a new house he said he used to
take his young boys 10 one or two of our
here tonight and we're your sons who are
your son's here let's see the show of
hands we got the mccarton family here
Mike I have four sons two showed up
hahaha and he used to take these boys
trick or treating he said but there was
a house where lon chaney jr. lived and
he said he couldn't talk him into going
up there because they were scared of him
but because of the wolfman roles lon
chaney used to be so he rented a lot of
of celebrities and along the way and so
I peppered the the book with a little
bit of that too and so and then the
other eight men who I see Gail is here
Gail carpenter raise your hand Gail was
a witch was judgment judgment cartons
clerk for four years and years and so a
Mitch Miller used to mention still Mitch
was judges bailiff for all those years
so the families here tonight so we've
profiled the other eight men too
including alcala and and in craft and
Marlowe and several war and I think
you'll find that interesting reading as
well okay I think I've had my say here
and so I'm going to turned over the
judge and he's going to talk to you want
to remain seating and what do you think
he said I can't stand up the gentleman
here I don't know but he's been admiring
my wingtips and these are 1959 or 60
originals and he wants them when i leave
but i'll start out with a little offbeat
thing talking about shoes I couldn't get
into these first time it on a tennis out
of tennis shoes in about 15 years and I
used to try cases in my wide where my
jogging clothes underneath my robe and
my tennis shoes I get out and hurrying
it back but galas dead also these were
brought by my first original court
reporter she's here she brought me some
of these which she used to do the
tourneys house had to bring me donuts
right in here their cases so anyway
talking about shoes I'm really here to
see how many people does it take to
carry your casket how many pallbearers
you need anybody know I don't know six
I've got four sons and I'm short two
so I'd like a sign up if we could I'll
tell take anything and how about women
can they be pallbearers too i'm serious
i don't know i'm getting yes ok back to
the shoes i had a multi millionaire
billionaire live next door to me at Bass
Lake California his name was not Horst
he was Irish anyway he died and he had
millions of dollars old house san
fernando valley shopping centers and
sober and he was always dressed to a tee
and he take all his family on cruise he
had so much money we had a pair of black
patent leather shoes up there and he
died and so his daughter called me and
invited me to the funeral down in
westlake or some westlake village and so
forth so i went i supposed to go down
and i had no shoes because i was living
between costa mesa and bass lake so i
had a key to Henry so I went over and
borrow at Henry's patent leather shoes
to wear to the funeral so I walked in
and his daughter was sitting there and i
said i'm wearing hanks shoes you don't
mind do you and she just got cracked up
so anyway I get up there I'm Eddie
eulogy I want you to know i'm standing
in Hanks shoes today true story ok one
other thing the reason on getting back
to the book in alcalá the little girl
was killed was the picture girl that
they reversed the stream kicked all the
justices outta and she was the little
poster girl for that removing roseburg
and number two the day that i've got the
news and june twenty i think 1994 it
said alcala reversed thinners are read
further on that same date mr. Alcala
they picked up DNA from a 1977 murder
rape in Malibu and mashes DNA if you can
believe it on the same day they match
his DNA to a cold case so kind of ironic
let me
to that of my mind the man is going to
prosecute alcala on the next trial if it
ever happens and it was delayed by the
way because I'll calles attorney last
spring was vacation in the Caribbean and
drowned so and unfortunately the poor
guy is gone and so he had built up all
the way to reprice acute alcohol and now
it has to be postponed again because of
that the prosecutor is going to take the
case whom we've profiled in the book as
well Matt Murphy told me that not only
had had they matched Rodney to some cold
cases one cold case which we profile in
here Georgia wickstead who was murdered
in 1978 or 79 they got his DNA they you
know they took his DNA and they matched
at a computer DNA and they matched him
now to Georgia Wickstead murder just
tonight Matt showed up says there's two
more the LA County is matched him too so
even if Rodney Alcala is not convicted
on this next go-around he ain't going
free folks he's going to vote for LA and
they've got DNA unfortunately Matt Matt
Murphy faces a big big obstacle because
the appeals courts have have rejected so
much of the evidence using the previous
two trials it's going to be ver it's
going to be difficult it may may be able
to you may be able to get the the the
guilt verdict we don't know but in case
he doesn't alcala is going to still face
some other murder charges which is good
news and I in the book by saying maybe
there is perfect justice I'm sorry go
ahead judge now I lost my train of
thought getting back to alcalá one of
the difficulties is the main witness
closest to an eyewitness with a forestry
gal it had she observed alcohol in the
area and forth and she's the one that
found the little girl and so she and the
first trial she testified and in the
second trial we put her on the stand and
she couldn't remember share what they
call traumatic amnesia she could not
recall anything about the case so what
we had to do is we have psychiatrist so
for examiner
they all said you know she couldn't
recall she was the trauma the case so
she is out of it we had to read her
testimony back in to the record so
they're going the same problem here so
that's what made it so difficult because
the main witness doesn't know what
happened anymore so we're reading her
cold testimony back which doesn't
doesn't help but anyway and getting off
a little bit on this Angel of Darkness
actually with 68 murders and he a craft
had them under his back cedar in his
trunk when he was stopped they had a
list of 68 in a row by code names like
Huntington Beach something yet like
Hawaii five-o he killed five and a
weekend in Hawaii and they hey he was
the leading serial killer in the in
Oregon until I got the green river
murder he did five and a weekend in in
Oregon five in Michigan in other words
he was a busy man on a weekend his
journey would go around and repair these
computers use a computer expert so he
could put your system back together and
nothing flat but that's about we what
have there I don't know quite know where
or why or so forth if anybody has a
question please we said go to the
microphone and ask and I'll be glad to
answer it can I start I have a question
for you yeah I would like you to expand
a little bit what you told me that we
what we put in the book about the the
evidence of the so-called psychologists
and hypnotism that that the court said
you made an error by not disallowing can
you tell the folks a little bit about
that psychologist that you disallowed
the stew well I it wasn't a psychiatrist
we had psychiatrists testify that she
didn't recall and all that they brought
in a psychiatrist from irvine somewhere
and he was going to testify that
the officers when they test when they
talked to the Galahad the traumatic
amnesia that she was hypnotized if you
can believe that and they said she was
hypnotized and by the officers who knew
nothing about hypnotism where this came
from and that was one of the main
reasons I said I didn't allow this guy
to testify so it'd be a waste of time
and just confuse the jury but that was
about the way that went down and in that
particular case the only piece of
physical evidence we had were earrings
we picked up in a Washington search
warrant in the state of Washington they
had some earrings they turned to be out
to be the he was wearing the earrings of
the little girl he'd murdered in
Huntington Beach and they picked this up
from the dating game in other words he
was wearing the earrings he also won
something got to date him but that was
part of that case with a little unusual
let me explain about that but it was
really beat the investigators when they
were investing in this case that Rodney
Alcala was a suspect in the case and one
of the investigators went home one night
he was dead tired and he turned on his
TV and remember they all show the dating
game well he was about to fall asleep
and all of a sudden Jim laying the host
says and now our next in our next
Bachelor is Rodney Alcala and he told
all about him and and that there were
two other men of course and then this
pretty girl up there who's trying to be
real sexy and and Rodney is asking and
grinning like a fool and with with he's
with his leisure suit on because that
was in 1978 and Rodney one Rodney won
the day but I was told later by someone
that the date never took place because
Cheryl the girl who was a sherry Cheryl
who Rodney one had just recently broken
up with her boyfriend and the boyfriend
watched the show and it broke his heart
to see her on there and so he called it
that night and asked for a
reconciliation so Rodney never had the
date with her it never took place but
the investigator was just thrilled to
see Rodney Alcala on this show because
he would hope that someone else would
see
and then and then be able to testify
that they saw this man on the beach that
day were robbing Sam so disappeared
anyone else got some questions for the
judge now you probably can't make it the
microphone Kenny Jim doesn't been there
done that here comes one it was said
that you were on the bench for 15 years
and you tried over 300 cases how did you
manage to squeeze all that in well
number number one I saved a lot of time
because i wear my sweat sweat clothes
intended to none of my robe so i took
short lunches way that worked is
probably of all the murder cases
probably Oh half at least we're non-jury
trial even though there are murder cases
and the reason for that is under the
death penalty you have to have a you
have to have a a jury trial and in the
other cases there non-jury because
they're most a case whether it's
first-degree second-degree insanity
those type of flee like remember the
shooting of in flirtin where the seven
got slain out there and so forth in
fullerton and he was found not guilty by
reason of insanity and so earth well the
diverse from that I inherited that case
and those were dis Santa Dee hearing but
in a normal case they would really have
a judge decide who knows the difference
between first-degree second-degree
manslaughter and so forth rather than
the judge so you'd try murder caged a
couple of days and the attorneys that
had a good good defense or good sanity
plea and so they would go ahead and we
had two or three judges over here the
non-jury murder cases so half m wid be
without a jury and it was just there
were simples cut and so forth so that's
the way that worked so it was easy it
doesn't sound like
you'd do that but one thing about mike i
did as i said the last to first two
years on divorce trials and then the
next 39 on murder cases but once in a
while a case would end and you would
have a little bit of extra time and
source so they would have marb
mitchellson maybe some of you have heard
of before the divorce lawyer just died
so well I'd have mitchellson to my
courtroom they send me a two-week trial
and I'd say how am I going to get rid of
it in you know one day he said you'll
settle it so Miss Wilson you with trying
the what are the Japanese restaurants in
town the what's name of this benihana
they had about 30 benihanas the courts
have split up and of course he came in
Mitch mitchellson came in about five
o'clock into my courtroom and I've known
him from before I had divorced cases
with him and so forth I said well I said
what do you want to settle this case
Mitch how much you want for your
attorneys fees and we offered when he
wanted an attorney's fees gave her a
couple restaurants in that case was over
with in about an hour so there no
there's a way that way to go one story
it isn't in the book because I figured
might get kicked out of the sheriff's
office and he grinning at me over there
and the thing is about you know nobody
sequester's juries anymore you know the
old days I used to try case then I had
sequester the jury all night and so
forth I mean you have to keep them
overnight so sequestering injury is a
lot of expense so in the craft case my
do you want to raise your hand back
there young man was too son anyway Mitch
in my book I said I want to be
reincarnated as a bailiff because I do
absolutely nothing anyway myth said he
was short on money and if I'd sequester
the jury he would make a lot of money
that's the true story on why we
sequestered the craft hurry and little
anecdote here okay a couple of years ago
I got called a jury duty and I went over
to west court and I was sitting there
and I was panelled in this one judges
and I wanted so much to get up there
because I wanted the judge who was judge
Mike mccarton who's standing back there
in the yellow shirt on his son and I
wanted so much to get up there be
questioned and tell him well yeah I do
know a few people in the profession I
know your dad pretty well but I didn't
get called up there darn fit so so judge
McCartney there's my chance I do know
your dad and I also acknowledge an
audience here is one of the a very
prominent p I private investigator from
the city of Long Beach my friend Walt
swanage ER so why don't you I can't say
that name still is that he's
investigating a great and was over in
the courthouse investigating several
cases that a prominent cases well I'm
sorry go ahead I lost my train of
thought I i retired 1993 and retired
judges you can sit on cases if you want
and so anyway i retired in 1993 and when
was the Northridge earthquake 1993
anyway make a long story short judicial
commission called and asked if I would
take the case of mr. eng remember mr.
ang well I see a lot of Nadia let a
little darling that escaped his partner
Lake committed suicide in a ningun to
Canada for ten years took him 10 years
get him back and have been in Calaveras
County he's the one to cook the people
in the ovens up there the 12 of them or
whatever it was and mr. Inge had been in
Calaveras County and they gone through
six judges they had everything one had
an alcohol problem sore so they called
me on the phone and said mccarton you're
going to take the in case and it wasn't
that far hour drive from Bass Lake was
halfway but anyway I was supposed to go
for the in case and the morning in the
in case I had some kind of a hearing and
it was the day of the earthquake we
couldn't get out so Gary Proctor a good
friend of mine who will be I don't want
to say it we've got a book signing
tomorrow at borders at two o'clock
anyway to make a long story short and
they made the first pay they made the
paper border
I shouldn't say too much it says it says
don't judge the book by a federal
court's decision but anyway that's
Newport Beach they hit the borders but
anyway getting back to mr. Inge and we
brought him from fulsome in a specially
built it was a cage with four in it was
he was brought to court in an actual
cage they had built for me since an
escape risk so they towed this thing if
you can believe it from Fulton and
brought him in let him out of the cage
and brought him into the courtroom but
he I talked the attorneys and he had all
the attorneys on the Simpson case and
all all of all of those and they said
that I said look we got to get out of
Calaveras County because they'll hang
this guy in the street they'll do real
real justice up here so I gotten to
agree to go to judicial council and send
the case wherever the Jewish will
console why nice well that's okay
because I thought to go to Sacramento
and or San Francisco because he'd murder
somebody else up there too so anyway
once your district Commission came back
and they Senate Orange County which is
interesting because they must have
figured out I lived in Orange County so
I ran into a real naps nest up there
when I returned to court they said you
conned us you did this you did that and
so forth and so to make a long story
short they brought all sorts of motion
so I had to go ahead and get attorneys
out of Sacramento some big firm in
Sacramento they represented me to make a
long story short it was sent to orange
guy but the attorneys I had up there
this what comes around goes around the
store is the gala represented me in the
app in the office in Sacramento up there
and so on she was reading Folsom rough
wolf and she said if I'd known your
famous I would have been nicer to you
by the way if you if you want to read
really a good really a super good book
about Charles hang read die for me which
I wrote it was on I was on last just
last night as a matter of fact arts and
entertainment the American justice
series with Bill Curtis they did a
really good documentary on that and I
got to appear on that a few times so it
was on last night so and you can check
right here they might have it right here
in barnes and noble i hope well speaking
of A&E there I came down here and be
interviewed on by mr. Lassiter on this
book and the same time they got me over
the courthouse a and E and did an
interview on a lot of you probably
remember that and rule and if you really
love me they're doing a anything on the
little girl cinnamon brown that's coming
up in A&E but I don't know when it won't
let me know but I think that another
question coming up wall judge McCartan I
have a special interest in the Randy
Kraft case for actually three different
reasons the first one is that my
son-in-law grew up with Randy Kraft in
little city over here called midway city
on highway 39 the second interest I had
I was retained to do an investigation
regarding a missing person and I started
work on the case and woke up and read
the press-telegram one morning and ahead
came floating in down in Long Beach and
it turned out that that was one of Randy
Kraft's victims and my my clients son so
I attended the penalty phase of the
trial it was a very long trial nine I
think you had was it 16 convictions on
that 16 and so my question specifically
is I know that there were everybody had
wild guesses as to how many other
victims
but Don mentioned 60 tonight when the
trial was going on we're talking about
40 or 45 how difficult was it when you
had 16 different convictions in that
trial and and also do you have any
speculation or knowledge as to the
potential number of victims actually I
know exactly because it was documented
each one at 68 and law enforcement of
the 68 they tied in 45 Ron they tied in
actually 45 and they couldn't trace 23
and the strange thing is when I was
about to sentence Randy Kraft I got a
letter from a lady in Iowa another one
in Corona del Mar asking me if I had
more information or rating on any of
these other killings and sorry and he
had San Bernardino he had ten out there
at least and in this particular I
actually asked Randy Kraft as it's just
between us you know someday you want to
may want to help us out and solve some
of these cases I said the sentencing but
he of course never incidentally he's
that my clerk a Christmas card that will
show you I got one too
okay talking about clerks and so forth
I'll diverse for a minute I was trying
to case I never look at a case ahead of
time and so on and I was saying that the
bailiff did nothing and I said one of
the jobs of the clerk was to stitch up
the judges thurlow socks as a runner
with sharp toes and I would go through
these thur lows and they would have
holes in the toes so I'd given the gale
and she darn when she wasn't busy during
a murder trial she would darn my socks
so I I told a story to the jury I said
what Gil does is do take care of the
judges socks my thorough suck it turned
out to this particular case they had
killed the victim by shoving socks down
her throat and putting her in the
bathtub and I could see the DA who knew
what was going on I didn't and the color
drained out of his face as I'm talking
about you know my suck so that was not
the highlight of my judicial career of
what's who are very few what was it the
highlight when the african-american girl
was up there and and you were lecturing
her and you said it's time to call a
spade a spade yes I he said that I did
that in Cajun and anybody somebody's
making their way for the microphone i
also got sent to the Judicial Commission
for I was trying to tell for burglary
burglarizing taxi cabs in town and he
was a colored man black whatever you're
supposed to call these particular days I
don't know and so they the his attorney
said look judge mccarton we're not going
to get a fair trial there are no no
blacks on the jury and I said well this
is orange county we've got one percent
blacks we can do one of two things when
you either do nothing or pass out some
black paint and Lowanna hold this little
fellow had he worked for MGM and when
they caught him he was dressed as a
white businessman made up and had all
this white makeup up
and it came off as they captured him so
you know I was relating to you know
black paint because of when they caught
him and so the DA here tomm done isn't
here but he saved my judicial career by
explaining that so fire okay so I have
two questions the people that have a
problem with the death penalty mention
two things and I'd love to hear your
thoughts on it because my family knows
you very well and respects you
tremendously and so I'd love to hear
what you think of both the issue of DNA
seeming to tree overturn death penalty
cases and is that how does that impact
your thoughts on it but the second one
is it seems like we end up spending more
money trying capital cases and all the
appeals and then we would have paid if
we just kept them in jail for life so
should that come into it at all that
it's just so costly to go after a death
penalty well a great you hit a nail and
a head the great myth is that it's a
more expensive to keep a prisoner alive
you know death is off the role that that
is more expensive actually it's much
much more expensive to kill somebody
than it is to put them block them up
forever so that's a myth and it's wrong
and sober and even it's actually the
Madison and Farrell which did my used to
learn my attorneys papers and sore and
then I ran into years later I ran into
Mike Farrell who is anti death mr.
anti-death and so far so it's a it's a
small world name-dropping for a couple
minutes my law firm owned the Miami
Dolphins does that impress you
well they're lousy enough with a anyway
my I start out the practice of law in
Minnesota and everybody's from Minnesota
so anyway Joe Robbie was bought to miami
dolphins for fifty thousand dollars from
the Commissioner of the AFL was Joe Foss
in South Dakota and Ida left the firm by
then it was Makaha was Robbie mccarton
and Hoffman I'll get to Hoffman in a
minute but anyway make a long story sir
I that Joe Robbie ended up buying the
Miami Dolphins after i left for fifty
thousand bucks and Dan if you know Danny
Thomas Joe Robbie looked like a double
of Danny Thomas so I didn't I didn't
never know where Joe got the 50,000 so I
went back for my reunion 50 years later
and brought my wife along she'd never
been there and never believed anything I
told her so anyway we went back and bob
hoffman picked us up at the airport well
Bob law firm has been a mall of america
edmonton mall etc seven he was a mayor
of Bloomington and he also put all those
malls together that was that was Hoffman
but anyway I asked him where did Joe
ever get 50 grand he said he borrowed it
from danny thomas they were high school
classmates and lebanon together and so
what comes around I now know but anyway
a little additional answer to your death
penalty question we do deal with that in
the book we try to explore a little bit
about DNA as applied to the death
penalty and the problem of possibly
executing someone who is innocent and
those who are now being cleared through
DNA and so we propose that that all
people on death row should be tested and
and all their trial records gone through
very carefully to see if there's any
possibility that DNA would clear them
and if so do that test and do the
clearing now before we execute someone
who's innocent and so I think that would
probably prevent a serious tragedy if
that will
happen I don't know if it will happen
but we suggested in the book I'm but I'm
ambivalent as I'm for the death penalty
I'm ambivalent now because nobody
California Smoot I see Iowa for the
first time was putting somebody can ran
an execution through this past week but
it doesn't affect me because number one
the Federal Court has reversed all my
cases practically in other words it's
getting ridiculous and on this Robin Sam
so the poor mother's gone through she
was notified 10 or 11 years ago of an
execution date and asked if she wanted
to go to his execution and I received
letters from the governor or asking my
views and so forth and I actually
thought he made why I knew nobody has
ever executed so I didn't think it ever
went through but she thought he'd been
executed and then picked up the paper
that was first you knew about it Oh
another issue on the death penalty judge
had a didn't he didn't realize this i
don't think but he had one more
overturned and you folks need to watch
for it because the US Supreme Court is
going to consider it in their current
session a man named Gary Payton killed a
young woman in Garden Grove and while
Gary Payton was awaiting trial in Orange
County Jail he suddenly turned very very
religious and he formed his own ministry
in jail well when it came time to
administer to sentencing to death the
prosecutor said I see no mitigating
circumstances the Ninth Circuit the
court decided that his that Peyton's
conversion to religion was a mitigating
circumstance and that mccarton made an
error by not allowing that to as part of
the issue in deciding death or not so
that's going all the way to the US
Supreme Court so watch the papers
that'll be coming out soon and we cover
Gary Payton story in detail in this book
as well so you'll be watching for that
one any more questions you want to be
helped to when you want to be helped to
the microphone Jim
oh I got somebody there
you want to use this one I'm sorry what
you have a question for my question is
coming from my shares you have my
questions based on the same the same
subject now in California we have how
many convictions but it's only one so
very very rarely anybody's executed so
how many hundreds of years worth of
people we have waiting to be executed
now and then you consider the expense
and the chances of somebody actually
being the sentence being carried out I'm
just curious about your thoughts on that
subject
well actually there are over 650 men on
death row and about 13 women in this
state and as you if you're reading
current news you realize we've executed
10 some people say 11 but that counts
one who went who with them it was
convicted here and they went to Missouri
and was convicted executed in Missouri
for crime there so we've done 10 since
the death penalty was restored in the
late 70s after the supreme court
overturned it so that's not effective
administration of the death metal oh we
all know that and we deal with this in
the book we wind up the book by pointing
out that either that has to change or we
might as well get rid of the death
penalty because we're spending billions
of dollars to have these penalty trials
and then the night the appeals courts
are just saying well put a moratorium on
that delay it and and they're delaying
it for decades so we don't have an
effective death penalty in this state we
have to acknowledge that so something
has to change or we could just get rid
of it you agree judge I agree well I
think we've just about used up our time
okay well well go ahead one that was
sent to Missouri was that outsourcing I
don't know did you have one last
question only you mention ding and that
you had a possible brush with that and I
also know that you were shortlisted to
replace the original judge on the
Peterson case how if you had been named
to replace edge but how would you be
handling things differently for Scott
Peterson on the Peterson case depending
Scott number one asking for the death
penalty in Scott Peterson's case is a
complete waste of time effort and energy
because without without any prior record
and believe me I've never had anybody
who doesn't have prior criminal record
they're going to have a sentencing phase
they have nothing put on the DA and so
what they're doing they overcharged
he'll know more go to his chance of
going to death row are as good as mine
they'll never convict him of the death
penalty so what they're doing is scaring
the jury in the penalty phase
if they convict this guy they're gonna
get nervous say what do we do then so
what they'll do is compromise it and
agree if they do convict them that in
the death penalty case this guy walk I
guarantee it's a complete waste of time
oh I'm predicting a hung jury on that 1i
just they're not going to come back with
a kilt on him is gonna be a hung jury
well I think it's time for us to start
signing some books here and move the
books okay run agree okay well if you
want to come up and grab one we'll both
put our pencils to them thanks very much